good morning day number three in Ecuador  on our discoveries three endless and  we're starting today at the Inca ruins  of India pika the impressive thing about  the Inca culture and inca ruins is if  you have a closer look at the buildings  and you see how they set up the stones  so there you can see that they are  almost no gaps at all those that those  stones fit perfectly into each other  which is quite amazing if you just think  about how old is cultures  we are in Cuenca and the morning to  discover the old town wanker is located  in the south of the country and the old  town is also unesco world cultural  heritage site beside that it's a quite  relaxed City a great place to be we went  on top of a big building to see cuenca  at night  it's party time and can heal  you  next thing is the race of the coiffure  hooray of the guinea pig  now we have the crazy cow running around  in the next episode we will head back to  Quito and explored region north and east  of the capital  you